i was thinking the other day about
about racism because obviously i think
about it a lot
and we've discussed it before on here
riley
would you agree with that
well i think that here's what i'm
thinking is
nowadays you see a lot of children a lot
of mixed children
you know you see somebody and we talked
about it last a couple weeks ago there's
somebody's japanese and
uh and filipino
you know or you see somebody that's um
you know from delaware and also somebody
that's uh
malaysian you know
malware they'll call them or whatever
but when i was young they called them
mixed oh look at that little mix fella
you know you'd see a kid he'd have a
white body one black leg
you know you'd see a kid he had a little
you know maybe he was ten percent uh
you know maybe he was ten percent um
pinoy and he'd have one kind of lean eye
you know it was just different man you
see you know what they call a mix though
that little fellas mix look at him
you know you'd see a little uh you see a
black kid but he'd have long blonde hair
you know when he'd perm his own hair at
night
he's like oh damn he's something you
know
so it was just a different time people
were more mixed but i'm thinking that
because there's still some racism out
there
you know and i'll name a couple of
groups that do not get along really well
or if they get along well but there's
still some tension that's a better way
to say it
black and white
chinese and black
also mexican and black in prison
okay and this is all stuff that i've
heard from verified people
and the rumor is black versus alien
or extraterrestrial et's
you know i have a lot of black friends
that have told me that there is
low-key beef between extraterrestrials
and the urban community
um do you know any rally any
ra what groups that have racial tension
um
japanese and germans there you go
and there you go right from the little
horse's mouth right there you heard it
and where'd you hear about it um
in school for one okay but also for
another
you know a few of my friends that are
german
sorry about that i have
an email account but here's what i'm
thinking is the one the way we get to
the future because you see a lot of
these fellas now a lot of these ladies
that are doing well when it's
mixed culture you got your patrick
mahomes is out there
this guy i mean who knows what he's
doing this dude do anything he wants
you got who's somebody that's mixed that
does well riley
um me
who else i'm trying to think of a female
there's definitely other people
but here's what i'm saying is that this
i think eventually all the ra
every race will be mixed in two three
centuries you're gonna have everybody is
gonna be
part everything and then that's when
everything gets unlocked you know like
we kind of unlock some of the key to the
universe when you get to that
you know that kind of captain planet um
type [ __ ] basically
because here's the thing that's the
thing it's a magic deal
because everybody's still you know
people still kind of cornering off for
their respect
people still blocking out posting up for
their own races a lot
and um i think the the key to it all is
is once you get all of that
all of the rate once it's all mixed
completely
and you get that you know japonetric
mahomes basically when you get that
full it's almost like if you took around
a cup at a united nations meeting
you know or even just a hand you put
your hand out like that
hit everybody ejac into your hand at a
uh
u.n rally or something or a mixed event
and you mix all of that up
and you should put that [ __ ] in the oven
on high for about
three hours bro i bet when you open it
up
you got it just a big bunt cake that
would never ever be racist
and i believe that a thousand percent
man
so i'm just trying to think outside of
the box you know i'm just trying to
think of things that could
be this be the end game
you know i'm just trying to think of the
things that would be the end game
evening good afternoon and other times
thanks for watching that video you just
saw
i mean it was okay but the next video
you can watch
could be way better what if you watch a
video right now that changes your life
well you could watch this one or watch
this one watch this one watch this one
watch this one